man I love you to death I [ __ ] hate
you for getting that shark song stuck to
my [ __ ] baby shark I like that song
baby sharks to do baby shark doo doo de
doo to do baby shark/doo doo doo doo de
doo de doo I played it for my wife and
she was like oh what is that I go you
don't know baby shark what is that the
karaoke yeah oh wow they put out karaoke
baby [ __ ] I made that you made that I
made that ya know did it here no [ __ ]
yeah I thought we were gonna go back to
it but we never circled back so I saved
it why keep kind enough Oh Bravo sings
do it I'll be like I like to do that
Robin wants to hear me I'll sing till
everyone turns out I don't like your bed
I cried doesn't sound the same it's
close no okay when did you make that I
made that yesterday when you guys were
singing it but then you went away from
it oh you made it during the show during
the show how do you do that I had my
laptop out and I use GarageBand wonder
he's in he's busy I see I mean you
didn't tell anybody
well it's one of those things when it
comes up it's a nice one you just tell
me in the commercial oh I see
ya wanted me to be surprised but it
never came up again so it was all for
nothing but it did come up today don't
you think fred is the strangest person
you ever met uh not the strangest but he
definitely is strange this is the only
show where you can do something good and
give it wide up but why not tell
everyone about it because then you go
I'm done with it
but but give me the option in other
words you went ahead and made a whole
bed during the show great friend a big a
shark right and then you never told me
right Wow how's he supposed to know well
when he sings about it today I play it
this I mean sound so are you making a
song right now No
holy mackerel
who knew that's what Fred does yeah well
sometimes I'll do that during the show
make a song yeah and then I thought many
times that we use one of those song
never couple at least no because he
doesn't tell me not true this is the
karaoke version you like kind of doing
already good we wasted all that time
making a version I'm not even used when
there was a karaoke version and I spent
the last five minutes getting beat up
for mommy shark - dude it is to do mommy
shark they do they do mommy well why
would you make an aversion of your own
when there's a karaoke version maybe I
thought I'm saying I love this guy I
mean I'm working like almost 40 years
doo-doo-doo-doo by me shark do tooted
and this one's perfect
mommy shark mommy shocked it you did it
to mommy shark they did it is to do
mommy shark what was the karaoke version
lacking that made you I don't know I
know he just likes making I didn't even
know if there was one but why don't you
check I don't know I thought I'd make
one this guy I love them don't get me
wrong I love do love you not really
feeling oh you mean you spent all that
time making a [ __ ] bed when there's a
karaoke no no no there was one and then
didn't tell me but nobody told me about
the karaoke persons you like Fred right
Robin
why exactly just this conversation isn't
exactly reflecting that one look why do
you love Fred I mean I I you know deep
down yeah he has the best of intentions
right right okay I just needed a
reminder doesn't like intention well
good for you Fred
I Love You Man I don't care what you say
what you do and I love you even though
everything that you're saying doesn't
indicate so no you keep making beds and
not telling yeah
you know fred has a catalogue of 500
songs you know what I think I prefer it
everyday what do you think of that